foreign
[Music]
and I'm a professor of mathematics at
the University of California Irvine my
main interest is evolution and I spend a
lot of time studying cancer because it's
an example of an evolutionary process
that is very useful to understand
so today uh I will present some recent
work
about the protective effect of aspirin
in colorectal carcinogenesis
this work
encompasses two very different
spatial scales one is microscopic so
what happens inside cells how mutations
happen how Evolution proceeds inside
um
small compartments in an organ on the
other hand we have the scale of
populations of people epidemiology
cancer epidemiology
and it turns out that there is a very
clear connection between the processes
that happen on the microscopic scale of
cells and uh the epidemiology of cancer
so mathematical tools that I will
present uh allow us to build this
connection and make a predictive model
of what happens in this case when uh
people take aspirin and how this may
help perhaps prevent or delay uh the
development of cancer
so I will start with the mathematics of
the microscopic scales and briefly
explain how we can use various tools to
understand evolutionary processes that
happen uh in dividing populations of
cells
and then we'll go and connect that with
epidemiology
so mathematics of cellular evolution
I want to start with this very old
diagram that shows the progression of
colon cancer
uh as you can see we start with normal
epithelium and it goes to adenoma and
then light adenoma and so on this
process is a multi-stage carcinogenesis
and it goes over several mutations that
are often present in colon cancer and I
want to attract your attention to uh two
types two different types of mutations
that are there
one of them is called loss of function
mutation and the other one is the gain
of function mutation so the first one is
a tumor suppressor Gene here it's the
example given here it's the APC Gene and
the gain of function limitation is an
oncogene in this case k-ras so what are
these types of mutations
a loss of function a gain of function
mutation is when a mutational process
happens in the cell and as a result the
phenotype of the cell changes and it
requires some Advantage so perhaps it
starts growing faster or dying slower so
an example is an oncogene KRS that's
involved in the
colorectal carcinogenesis and it's
always the one step process right one
mutation is enough to create a cell that
has these different properties that is
somehow fitter than the rest of the
population
uh on the other hand a loss of function
limitation is a two-step process so uh
you may know about tumor suppressor
genes they're about a hundred of them
that have been discovered in different
cancers one of them is APC another one
is retinol blastoma and so on so uh in
in the wild type cell uh the tumor
suppressor Gene is present in two copies
of course and it's function that is
relevant for us is that it prevents bad
things from happening it prevents cells
from
breaking from cooperation from starting
to grow so fast and so so the first uh
mutational event inactivates one of the
copies of the gene but there's still the
other one that keeps bad things from
happening so after the first mutation
nothing much happens in terms of the
um Fitness of the cell and one hit
mutant has similar properties to the
biotep cell it can be actually its
Fitness can be slightly reduced uh
compared to the wild type cell because
the gene performs other functions so in
activation May reduce the fitness
and only the second
mutational event the inactivation of the
second remaining copy will result in
increased Fitness of that cell because
now both copies are inactivated and the
cell starts acting up
it's like Mr growing too fast or dying
too slow so it has an increased Fitness
so mathematically these are very
different processes and uh they have
been studied widely so here I uh I will
give an example of how we could study
loss of function mutation uh so one of
the important questions is to calculate
the rate of tumor suppressor Gene
inactivation it's a two-step process so
uh how quickly do we expect something
like this to happen in a pop in a small
compartment of a cellular tissue right
so we always start with a wild type cell
uh and mutations happen
very infrequently so here you can see
the mutation rate is in this case 10 to
the minus seven per cell division per
Gene copy so not very often right so uh
this very rare event gives rise to a
one-hit mutant and then those have to
give rise to to hit mute how long does
it take right so uh imagine a small
compartment
for example a colonic Crypt I will
mention that later
uh and uh cells engage uh in the process
of Divisions and deaths in this
idealized mathematical model uh which we
call a Moran process each cell division
is balanced by a death so it goes like
this so uh I suppose we pick a cell for
death so here's crossed out it's gonna
die and we pick another cell at random
for division so it keeps going like this
and some in this
diagram we
use purple for wild type cells and light
green for a one-hit mutant so somehow we
go through the process where each death
uh is um balanced with the division so
the total population remains constant
and eventually the second mutation
happens and that's where we say okay our
event has has taken place the tumor
suppressor Gene has been been activated
in one of the cells and now we have the
super mutant that may take over the
population right this could be one of
the first events in carcinogenesis so
mathematically speaking
um
we can formulate this stochastic process
each cell is equipped with the division
rate and a death rate and mutants may
have a different division and death
rates compared to Wild types right we
can run this uh we can run computer
simulations that show how this proceeds
so here
um this slide shows three different
dynamical regimes that can occur uh in
this very simple system so depending on
the mutation rate and how it Compares
with one over n the population size
there are three possibilities here on
the left we start with the whole
population being wild type population as
we should then after a long time
a mutant a one-hit mutant is generated
and uh it takes over right and that sits
there so the whole population consists
of one hit mutants you can see single
mutants there and uh finally one of
those produces a double mute and that's
indicated in red now the whole
population consists of double hit
mutants right so this is what happens
when the mutation rate is very small
events compared to one over n where n is
the population size
uh the diagram in the middle is a
different regime so now uh
one hit mutants
appear and they may linger for a while
and go away and linger for a while and
go away but before they ever take over
uh they create a second mutant and that
mutant dominates the population this is
a double mutant Super Mutant that is
stronger so this regime we call
stochastic tunneling
and it requires some different
mathematics to calculate and finally all
the way on the right we have a situation
where the mutation rate is the largest
uh compared to one over n and uh from a
stochastic process which is subject to
Randomness we have an almost a
deterministic process things always
happen in the same way and this is the
least relevant regime for us because
the mutation rate is uh not large
compared to 1 over n in all relevant
situations so we can formulate this
problem by using a course grade
description I will skip over the details
my point is that uh
uh
we uh
create a model where all the rates can
be calculated depending on the kinetic
parameters division rates of cells death
rates of cells mutation rate and the
population size right uh so now that was
very naive because cells don't live in a
box like this uh they um uh exist in
space so let's look at the spatial model
here uh it's an example of a
two-dimensional uh Moran process
where when a cell dies
not anybody else in the population can
be chosen for division but only somebody
in the neighborhood right so cells in
this case know about their spatial
location and they can only replace uh a
dead cell in their own neighborhood so
it kind of proceeds like this we uh
keep going
uh until the first double hit mutant is
generated right and this is a more
complicated mathematical problem so here
we present the solution in a
one-dimensional case uh uh and there are
also solutions that were obtained by
others uh such as Rick durat in
two-dimensional three-dimensional cases
and it turns out that the rate at which
mutants are generated is faster just
because there's a space involved so it
has to do with the existence of mutant
islands that kind of tend to Cluster
together and protect weaker uh
intermediate mutants from dispersing and
being out competed by the wild type
uh finally I want to mention a third
type of models that have been used to
study this process where a little bit
more realism is added so we have to
remember that not all cells are the same
they're stem cells and there are
differentiated cells and all types of
intermediate cells so in this uh simple
stake on this process we have a
hierarchical
structure where uh there are different
stages of uh differentiation that cells
go through so the here the last cells
are removed and then the previous uh
generation divides and so on until the
stem cell that's kind of sitting at the
bottom divides and the process starts
over in this case we could also
calculate uh the rate of evolution or
the rate of tumor suppressor Gene
inactivation and it turns out that it's
slower
compared to the previous two models so
to recap just this spark
um
what is the
um kind of take-home message from this
mathematical work we're going to explore
different scenarios we can see how
different aspects of the system
um contribute
to the rate of evolution
right so for example we can calculate
the rate of evolution and see how it
depends on uh the uh underlying system
so this slide shows three lines
it plots the rate of evolution as the
function of a mutation rate in the three
different models that I have mentioned
so far so the line is in the middle is
the math action model the simplest one
where we don't have any space we don't
have stem cells nothing just a simple
box of cells so uh if we add spatial
interactions uh that makes the evolution
proceed faster
uh but if we add a hierarchical
structure
it makes evolution slower
so uh it's possible that uh one of the
reasons why organs
um especially epithelial tissues are
characterized with this complicated
hierarchical structure one of the
reasons for that could be to delay this
uh unwanted Evolution to delay the onset
of cancer to push it as far as possible
to you know have the organism reach the
reproductive age and only maybe later
develop cancer this is one of the
hypothesis that follows from this
mathematical Theory hierarchical
structure delays Evolution and helps
delay the onset of cancers of epithelial
tissues
so uh this was a very brief introduction
to uh the microscopic
type modeling uh that can be performed
and mathematical tools for which have
been developed
here we will apply it to colon so what
type of populations are we dealing with
so on the left here we have a picture
looking at colonic tissue and you can
see it consists of folds like this
they're called Crypts uh in the middle
you see an amplified picture or
schematic picture of a crypt it's a fold
of cells and there at the bottom there
are stem cells which are kind of of the
most important for us so that bottom
compartment is what you see on the right
this is what we see as our compartment
the the small compartment of cells and
that's where things take place this is
where all the action takes place uh
cells divide and die they replace each
other they compete that's where
mutations happen and uh this is where
colon cancer is originated
so in the second part of my talk I want
to connect this type of microscopic
modeling with a bigger picture
with the picture of uh epidemio
epidemiology of cancer
and in specifically I want to talk about
the role of aspirin as a possible uh
mean to
protect against cancer so I will start
with some experimental uh and
epidemiological evidence of uh the role
of aspirin and the main Central uh point
that I would like to discuss here
so uh these graphs
come from the famous cap to trial by uh
burn and colleagues that took place in
the UK they were looking at patients
with Lynch syndrome so that's one of the
ways to look into colon cancer so Lynch
syndrome is a familial disease where uh
one of the genes in patients is mutated
uh in The Germ line so they are born
kind of one step closer uh to colon
cancer so most of these patients develop
colon cancer and other cancers in their
40s to and 50s so this is a group of
people that are at risk
increased risk of developing colon
cancer so this is a group of people that
was used in the study
and uh there were split into the
subjects were split into two parts the
control group received the placebo
and others were given aspirin tablets
for uh a certain period of time and then
the incidence of uh colorectal cancer
was recorded So in the vertical axis
here is
um the uh proportion of the people
diagnosed with a Lynch syndrome cancer
and uh
the horizontal axis is years
since the beginning of the trial and the
blue line corresponds to the control
group so this is the proportion of Lynch
syndrome people who developed the
condition and the red is the patients
who received 600 milligrams of aspirin
and you can see that there is a
significant reduction in the risk of
developing
um cancer in in this group uh okay so
the next slide presents uh other uh work
that gives evidence to the same point
this is a meta-analysis of effects of
aspirin in cancer prevention by Baron
and colleagues so they compiled a number
of uh other of results from other
research groups and uh in the middle you
see those dots there's a vertical line
and there are dots to the left of it uh
they look at the relative risk of
developing uh cancer
by patients that received aspirin
treatment and this relative risk is less
than one it means that the risk is
reduced so you can see all those points
are on the left of the vertical line
vertical line is one so the relative
risk is less than one so we have a
reduced incidence of cancer in those
patients who were given aspirin finally
I want to represent the Third and Main
uh piece of evidence that is most
relevant to our own study this is the
study of Andrew Chan and colleagues it
was a large study of a large cohort of
nurses they looked at those depend those
dependent risk reduction uh of
colorectal adenoma in this uh subjects
in this table
uh you can see
um
first of all
um the some demographic data about the
participants and how many they were it's
a large study and the second table uh
shows risk reduction
in developing of adenoma
depending on the dose so we have zero
tablets per week uh half to one and a
half tablets per week
two to five tablets 6 to 14 and more
than 14. so 14 tablets per week is two
tablets per day per day so it's not
um a very it's a large dose but it's
something that people may take it's okay
so uh you can see that the strongest
dose uh taken per week led to a 50
reduction in the risk of developing uh
late uh colorectal adenoma so you can
see 0.49
um as a relative risk so this is what we
would like to explain how does this work
can we use mathematical modeling to
explain this it's a collaborative effort
I want to speak a little bit about my
colleagues so we have uh two
experimental collaborators uh it's uh
Aji goel and Rick Boland
they are oncologists
who studied uh
gastric cancers
and uh theoretical colleagues are
Dominic Waters from UCI and the former
postdoc he found one from UCI as well so
we have uh published a couple of
experimental papers with some
mathematical
estimation of parameters the first study
was an in vitro study then an in Vivo
study and most recently we published a
mathematical study that kind of uses the
experimental results to develop
mathematical Theory
so I will first mention or
the setup of the in Vivo aspirin studies
so our colleagues used mice and they
planted uh several different cell lines
as xenocrafts they use different uh
dosages of aspirin treatment for those
mice and they looked at the growth
curves of the tumors
uh under different dosages of aspirin so
here is a photograph of those tumors
that they measured as a function of time
these graphs are on the right this is
the tumor volume as a function of days
how quickly it grows and the different
curves correspond to different dosages
of aspirin the top curve is no aspirin
and those decreases as we go down
so we wanted to extract kinetic
parameters of cell division and death
from these curves so the equations on
the left show how we'll set it up here
this is a spatial model because this is
a solid tumor growing in
three-dimensional space so there are two
unknown parameters L the division rate
of the cells and D the death rate of
cells that we were able to extract from
these measurements and here are the uh
the the result of fitting of the
mathematical model to the experiments is
on the right and the here's the main
kind of result
um from this study the graph on on the
left shows the death rate of cells
uh as it changes with Aspirin dose and
and you can see for higher amount of us
amounts of aspirin the death rate of
cells increases the second graph is the
division rate of cells and you can see
that as we increase the aspirin dose the
uh division rate of cells decreases so
there are two things that we saw happen
to cells uh under the presence of
aspirin the cells one of the effects of
the aspirin that it increases the death
rate of cells and the second effect is
that it decreases the uh division rate
so basically it reduces the fitness of
the cells and will Quantified exactly by
how much right we have this quantity of
data uh showed the extent of this effect
in in xenografts the graphs on the very
right are similar results that we
obtained in the previous study in vitro
so both results are the same so we could
measure
um the extent of the change in the
parameters kinetic parameters of cells
as a result of different aspirin doses
okay so what we are trying to do here is
we want to explain how aspirin may
affect the incidence of colorectal
cancer and the information we have is
how it affects kinetic rates of cells
that we measured the these graphs here
uh especially the let's take a look at
the black dots this is age incidence
curves for adenoma
in the general population this is in the
absence of aspirin treatment just the
general population this is um some
epidemiological studies that have been
performed a large amount of data so now
uh we want to combine this with the
results of incidence reduction as a
function of aspirin dose and we want to
explain the reduction in the agencies
curve okay so uh how do we do this the
idea in this latest work was to create
and parameterize the model of late as a
normal generation implement the effect
of aspirin through modification of
kinetic parameters which we measure
connect that with epidemiological
population data and measure
aspirin-induced risk reduction and then
we will be able to see if our measured
effect of aspirin can explain the
reduction in age incidence curves so
this is the type of model that we're
going to use
um
microscopically right this this is the
small scale model except uh compared to
what I talked about at the beginning of
the stock it's going to be a little bit
more complicated I went over several
very simple models and I explained how
we can model just one
uh
type of event a loss of function event a
tumor suppressor Gene so this is here if
you look at the
diagram on the bottom left
it has six different states states one
two and three the top row uh denote the
transition from a wild type cell
to a cell with one copy of a tumor
suppressor Gene inactivated and then two
cells with both copies of tumor
suppressor Gene inactivated so this is
ABC minus minus
these are cells that have lost their
tumor suppressor Gene going down there
are three states four five and six they
have an additional mutation
which isn't a gain of function mutation
this is an activation of an oncogene
k-ras that is also implicated uh in uh
late adenoma
uh so the bottom right state state six
that is encircled in the red this is
what we assume the late or Advanced
adenoma to be they have both copies of
the APC Gene and activated and uh the
oncogene Keras activated so three
mutational events lead there uh also
included in the model is the uh process
of Crypt fission so uh before I was
talking about constant population but uh
now we are going to include a
biologically observed process where
modified genetically modified Crypts
that are partially mutated can actually
divide and the whole population
increases as a result so this is what is
shown in this diagram
we uh used a previously published model
uh as a starting point that uh so this
model includes these six states that uh
I mentioned and the most important state
state sticks is Advanced adenoma this is
what we're going to focus on and the
great thing about it is that a lot of
parameters of this model have been
measured so this work would be
impossible to perform say five years ago
or ten years ago we tried but we failed
because there are too many unknowns now
a lot of parameters are known so we can
fit the model very well we have to
modify the model to fit our purposes uh
we included some non-linearities uh and
so just to show you the result uh these
graphs uh or in on the left and the
middle show the error of fitting then
there's a large Valley so there are many
parameters that parameter values that
correspond to a very good fit so we
cannot say that we found like a unique
parameter combination that uh you know
corresponds to the the uh the model that
is best fitting we found a range and
that's okay so whatever work we do we
perform with the whole range of
parameters but we found a very good fit
the graph on the right shows the uh
observed incidence uh of late adenoma in
the absence of aspirin and the lines are
the best fits there are many of them but
they all fit very well so now the first
question we asked what is the most
likely pathway and this is still in the
absence of aspirin right what is the
most likely pathway that takes us from
Wildlife cells
to later the normal cells how is this um
what is the most likely sequence of uh
mutations that leads us there so on the
top left we have a diagram that shows
the yellow pathway so first uh the two
copies of APC General activated and then
we go down the oncogenous activated or
we have two green Pathways also the
three steps but in a different order
and so uh we performed fitting with both
types of sequences of events and the
yellow Pathways turned out to be the uh
best fit so we'll conclude that
according to our model uh it is mostly
like most likely that the first event in
the progression to later adenoma is the
inactivation of the tumor suppressor
Gene which is Then followed by an
activation of the oncogene okay so now
let's uh include aspirin in the model so
we're going to consider uh a certain
period of time from T start to TN where
we administer aspirin and then we
measure the resulting incidence of late
adenoma in such patients so how do we
incorporate aspirin in the model uh we
uh use the information that we obtain
from the experimental studies uh
and we just say Okay during aspirin
treatment the division rates of cells
are going to be affected in this way and
the death rates of cells are affected in
that way and we know exactly by how much
they change what what is the um
relative change for each aspirin dose so
this is summarized here in the table uh
so this is our model
and uh we uh consider two types of
effects that aspirin can have on cells
first of all it can be intracrypt
Dynamics uh so inside Crypts cells
divide and die faster okay so this means
that when aspirin has administered all
these rates that are encircled in red
are going to change in in the fashion
that we can predict okay we know how
much they change also aspirin can affect
the fission of the crypts because cells
divide slower than that faster so
something is going to happen to this
rate of uh Crypt division so that is
going to be reflected in the change in
these other coefficients
and this is uh the result
a number of results that this model
gives us if we assume that aspirin has
both effects so you can see that in
these graphs the green uh regions is the
age uh when we simulated the um
aspirin intake by people we use the
largest dose here which is more than two
or more tablets per day or 14 or more
tablets per week for 10 years
the black dots uh
denote the agency this curve as it was
measured and this was fitted by our
model and the yellow curve is what we
predict will happen if aspirin is taken
During the period of time in green you
can see that the earlier aspirin
treatment takes place the larger is the
reduction in the incidence the yellow
curve uh is lower for those people for
those
agents that we simulated agents that
took aspirin earlier on in their lives
if it is predicted that taking aspirin
from 50 to 60 still makes a big
difference but 60 to 70s the effect is a
little bit less in 70 to 80 it's even
less
now the next slide explores the uh role
of aspirin dose and we can see that we
can put in the parameters that
correspond to light those medium those
and strong dose and we can see that with
the strongest dose the effect could be
up to 50 exactly as uh was observed in
under chance studies of the cohort of
nurses uh but even the intermediate
those also uh gives a significant effect
um this uh slide explores the effect of
the length of treatment so obviously the
longer the treatment takes place the
larger the effect so this slide Compares
uh 10 years of aspirin treatment versus
five years of aspirin treatment the
diagrams on the right uh the the
plots on the right show in blue
treatment in five years and the yellow
treatment of 10 years five years is not
as effective but it still is a
significant effect especially if it's
taken earlier in life
um here uh it's more of a theoretical
question right so what exactly are the
processes that are affected by our
spirit is that mostly intra Crypt
Dynamics is it intercrypt Dynamics
script fission uh so we explored both
and this slide shows that the largest
effect uh is observed when we assume
that aspirin affects the Crypt fission
so this corresponds to uh the largest
reduction in the age incidence curve
to conclude
um
our previous in vitro and Vivo work
indicated that aspirin reduces the rate
of colorectal tumor cell division and
increases the rate of death in in a dose
dependent way up to twofold
then we did some mathematical modeling
and the analysis demonstrated that
parameter change within our
experimentally observed range can lead
to up to 50 reduction in the age
incidence curve of later genoma the
model it identified those treatment
duration and the age at which treatment
was started as important determinants of
protection so uh further studies will
confirm exactly in which way uh this
factors influence uh the reduction but
we identified the predicted value
so we conclude that the aspirin-induced
changes in cellular Fitness that we
observed can in principle explain a
significant reduction in in Risk so it
doesn't mean that we've considered all
the effects of aspirin obviously there
are other things that happen there's a
mutagenic effect of aspirin that may
contribute there is also this whole um
uh issue of
inflammation and aspirin which is not
part of the study we just looked at the
simplest measurable effects of how
aspirin affects division death rates and
we showed that this can have a
significant effect on uh age incidence
curves so if you have any questions
please don't hesitate to enter those in
a q a box and I'll be happy to respond
to that those by email thank you very
much